Bonjour à toutes et à tous.
Ca fait plaisir de vous retrouver.
Quand on me dit matière noire,
moi je pense à ça, ça, ça, ça, ....
Alors que certaines personnes peuvent avoir des réflexions un petit peu plus élaborées.
Vous ne vous êtes jamais demandé
comment les galaxies,
ces immenses nuages d'étoiles et de gaz
liés par leur gravité
évoluent au cours de l'histoire du cosmos ?
Pour comprendre ces objets, on a plusieurs solutions.
On peut soit regarder les mêmes galaxies pendant plusieurs milliards d'années...
Ou bien on peut recréer toute l'histoire de l'univers dans une immense simulation informatique.
Étonnamment la deuxième solution est
de très très loin... la plus simple.
On ne peut pas mettre une galaxie sur une balance,
modifier la température d'une étoile
pour voir ce qui se passe,
ou encore mettre un capteur tout près d'un trou noir.
Pour étudier l'évolution des galaxies,
les chercheurs... et les chercheuses
ont donc recours à ce qu'on appelle
des simulations cosmologiques
qui ont pour but de rejouer l'évolution de l'univers selon les prédictions de nos meilleures théories.
Bon évidemment, on n'est pas dans Matrix. Il ne s'agit pas de reproduire l'univers à toutes les échelles.
On n'a juste pas la puissance de calcul pour.
Pour le moment...
Ces simulations se concentrent donc seulement sur la formation des plus grandes structures du cosmos.
Les règles du jeu ici ce sont les lois de la physique,
qui gouvernent comment la gravité fonctionne,
comment les gaz se comportent,
dans quelles conditions les étoiles
se forment et évoluent,
la composition initiale de l'univers,
etc.,  etc., ...
Ces simulations commencent quelques
centaines de milliers d'années après le Big Bang,
à une époque où l'univers n'est qu'un brouillard indistinct d'hydrogène et d'hélium.
Dans cette immense purée de pois, on peut néanmoins discerner quelques grumeaux.
Certaines régions sont très légèrement
plus denses que d'autres.
Et grâce à la force de gravité, plus ces grumeaux sont massifs, plus ils attirent de la matière autour d'eux.
Au bout du compte,
la matière va finir par s'arranger en immenses filaments
qui vont constituer ce qu'on appelle la toile cosmique
et sur laquelle vont se tisser,
au fil des milliards d'années,
les galaxies et les amas de galaxies.
Pour remplir votre univers virtuel primordial, vous aurez besoin de trois ingrédients principaux
Une cuillère à café de gaz intergalactique qui vous servira à produire vos étoiles et vos galaxies.
Une grosse louche de votre ingrédient secret
la matière noire,
c'est un peu le liant,
il faut absolument en mettre, sinon ça ne marche pas.
Le truc avec la matière noire,
c'est qu'elle n'émet pas de lumière
D'où le nom.
Vous voyez ?
Du coup comme elle est invisible à nos télescopes,
on ne sait pas encore ce que c'est.
Par contre on sait que cette matière noire, elle existe parce qu'elle a des effets bien réels.
Elle agit notamment par le biais de sa gravité
sur le mouvement des galaxies et
des amas de galaxies qu'on observe.
D'ailleurs la matière noire est au moins cinq fois plus abondante que la matière normale,
celle qui émet de la lumière
et qui constituent les étoiles, les galaxies et surtout ...
... Jean-Claude Van Damme.
Mais revenons à notre recette.
Il ne reste plus qu'à saupoudrer votre
simulation d'une pincée d'étoiles massives
qui explosent à la fin de leur vie
en éjectant des éléments chimiques lourds
dans le milieu intergalactique.
C'est avec ça qu'on fait des planètes,
des astéroïdes, de la vie,
et surtout...
Jean-Claude Van Damme
Laissez mijoter tout ça ensemble
pendant quelques milliards d'années virtuelles
dans de puissants supercalculateurs ...
Et voilà !
Il n'y a plus qu'à admirer vos galaxies et vos amas de galaxies se former et à les comparer aux vrais.
Les scientifiques du CRAL,
le Centre de Recherche Astrophysique de Lyon,
ont récemment lancé une énorme simulation cosmologique pour tenter de comprendre
comment le rayonnement et les explosions des étoiles massives limitent la croissance des galaxies.
En attendant la fin du calcul...
On se fait une toile ?
Cosmique !
Beau boulot !
Hey ! Pense à t'abonner
et à jeter un œil au "Sense of Wonder" !
Suivez-moi !
Je vous couvre...